[Music]
my trying balance this and not Mike with
a spacebar I don't have a convenient
guide to go forward and backwards so
today I'm going to talk about feature
platformer that we bought at kojic I'll
start by talking a bit about codex it's
off the company and then go into a bit
of detail on the design decisions that
we made in building this feature
platform and the problem we're trying to
solve with it so who or what is go check
so go check is an Indonesian company
it's a technology startup and we have a
wide variety of products and services
and as you can see on our app on the
right there there's just some of the
examples of the products and services
that we have the one that we're most
famous for is ride hailing on
motorcycles so the reason why it's ride
heading on motorcycles is because in
Indonesia there are some very unique
problems with traffic so a lot of people
don't know this but Indonesia is one of
the largest countries in the world by
population and they have a lot of
congestion in the city and he's like
Jakarta and one of the ways in which
Indonesians have solved the problem
there is by having projects but
basically motorcycle taxis and our first
service was actually a call center
basically it calls into you : and then
you'd get a motorcycle taxi same to you
so it's offline it's all telephonic
there's no application and our founders
are very data-driven and they collected
a lot of matrix and how people using
arts service and they realized that
there was a very big demand for more
services like this that solved your
logistical problems in in Indonesia so
the traffic is so bad in Indonesia that
people who often just spend hours like
3-4 hours in traffic in a day you plan
your day around it so we knew we wanted
to deploy some services and we launched
our first app in 2015 so that was a 6 or
services that we originally launched
the main ones being right heading food
delivery online shopping grocery
shopping and logistic services since
then we've gone to become a unicorn so
in the last three years we've gone from
basically a call center to a five
billion dollar company we now have 18
services and we in 2018 or setting our
sights on international expansion so
that's that's the main thing we're
looking at now it's it's growing our
footprint throughout Southeast Asia so
just some statistics on the scale so we
process around 100 million bookings a
month so we're an offline company even
though it's a technology company
well it's physical things moving around
so if we're talking about right heading
100 million bookings a month typical on
typical day you'll have hundreds of
thousands of drivers online at one time
just in Indonesia and we're currently
expanding into Vietnam as well we've
just launched some of our services there
we're planning to launch in Thailand
soon planning to go to Singapore soon so
the whole Southeast Asia is opening up
to us but just in Indonesia the scale
which we operate is massive so and all
18 products most of them we are the
biggest player it's a ride heading very
big but we have 250,000 merchants on our
platform so for free delivery just to
give you some context that means we're
the largest by volume free delivery
service in Southeast Asia and that's one
of our products so to talk about data
but because that's where we're here this
might imagine doesn't really arrange it
very well but it's basically each pixel
is a trip that's starting or ending so
if somebody's being picked up or dropped
off so this gives you an indication of
in Jakarta over 24-hour period how much
how many transactions we do so that's
one data point that we're looking at and
so the data is very important for us
because it affects everything we do in
terms of decision making so we have a
lot of machine learning models that that
take this data in real time and it will
make decisions based on that so as part
of the data science team it's my job to
make sure that data scientists are
efficient what they do it there's not
just about
models that are efficient but it's also
about having access to information and
understanding on customers
so one of the things that we set out to
do as engineers in the data science team
is to analyze how data science is really
are doing their work and see if we can
improve their efficiency so we had a
look at how they were spending their
time so this is just a rough time bar of
basically how data scientists were
spending their time so what we found is
that they were doing some tasks like the
color tasks or data science related
toast
well we what we deemed to be and they
were also doing some other tasks that
were breaking the abstraction where they
were entering into the world of
engineering a lot and especially if you
have a company that's growing very
quickly and as new teams where everyone
has many hats to wear this situation
comes up a lot so we identified two
areas that we wanted to target to
improve the efficiency of the data
scientist number one is the data
pipelines and the ETL that create
features and that's on the left-hand
side and then it's the model serving
side for the skirt for this for this
presentation we're only focusing on the
platform we both to solve this problem
and not the serving side but but the
feature engineering and the details and
the data pipelines and the fact that
data scientists were spending a lot of
time on infrastructure and automation
and scripting and things that they
shouldn't be doing that was really the
problem we tried to solve
so the first problem in in feature
engineering that we encountered was they
a pipeline jungles so with these data
scientists having to create their own
pipelines that often hack together their
own solutions so that use air flow or
they'll use bash or Python or whatever
they could find and they scrape together
raw data and they create some hacky
Jupiter notebook or something and they
create pipelines from that and it'll be
very unstable and brittle and before you
know it you'd have many of these
pipelines in production that or just
being duplicated they're building a lot
of technical debt they have weird inter
dependencies that you can't decode
unless you're part of that project so
this is one of the main rules you're
trying to solve is this
the increase of tech debt in terms of
data pipelines because you want to have
a very flexible environment where people
can just develop at the same time you
don't want you have to clean up and be
on call at night if any of these
pipelines go down oh and and we really
believe that data scientist should be
the ones watering these pipelines and
not engineers because engineers or not
they don't understand what's required
for the project of end of the day unless
you're just pulling base values or base
entities if it's anything derived or
complex than the data scientists should
be doing that of course it didn't scale
anything they both because they didn't
understand spark or any of these
distributed execution platforms so
that's another problem we try to solve
real-time features required engineers
this is one of the biggest challenges
for us is that often you'd have data
Sciences writing data processing
pipelines that create features it would
happen something like this where you
have raw data you process the data
create features you train a machine
learning model the model is put into
production the model is wrapped in an
application that's their model serving
application but in production it's going
to get a request trigger essentially
that'll ask it to infer something at
that point in time it needs features but
those features need to be available
within milliseconds so engineers they
need to come in to write the feature
transformations to produce real-time
features and this often requires
streaming data from Kafka or pops up or
some stream and it means you
reemployment those features and it's not
free they're not gonna give you hundreds
or thousands of features like you would
have in batch they can give you two or
three of your most important ones so we
wanted something to give you have as
real-time features for free and then the
consistency between training and serving
if you have people or engineers
redeveloping and serving then you have
an inconsistency because often feature
transformations in batch are done in
Python or sequel but they're used
done in Scala or Java or in some other
language in production and you'll find
that there's a model drift there where
your training and your inference are
happening on different days
and there's a real scope for it bugs to
creep in there another problem ever you
were trying to solve was this discovery
problem data scientists were siloed and
I didn't they couldn't see what other
data science were doing unless they
spoke to them over lunch or everything's
in some way so the visibility and the
discovery of features was really one of
the key things that we're trying to
solve by centralizing
all the features into a central platform
and then hand-in-hand oh that is
standardization when you're working with
especially with business stakeholders
they want to be able to understand the
model and what went into the model and
reason about the features because it's
not just because there's an overlap
between features and matrix essentially
and business matrix features often you
know there's a massive overlap there so
standardizing what it is that your
feature represents is very important for
us so the platform just to recap the
platform should allow us to standardize
feature definitions
alright I'll continue to use this one
okay so we already standardized feature
definitions very important the atomic
unit of the feature would be the central
thing that we focus on in this platform
now this is gonna be easier so we wanted
to provide a means for means for data
scientists to author or publish features
so both in batch and in streaming so one
thing is important to know here is that
baton streaming in this context refers
to the source so doesn't refer to the
destination so all these features need
to be available in the training surfacer
at the store as well as in you're
serving store and then serving it needs
to be at low latency we needed to be
able to produce training sets to train
our models we needed these features to
be able to or the production services to
be able to reach these features in
serving and then allow for discovery of
these features and then abstract away
the engineering problem and abstracting
the way engineering is the number one
thing that we're focusing on here is
drawing that line between allowing then
effect to give them a flexible system
where they can create features access
these features in production or train
their model and at the same time not
have to worry about storage or
scheduling or automation or dead later
queues or retries or anything like that
so not a good a good way to talk about
this is in the context of a specific
problem that we had so this is one of
the models that we have in production
and it's one of the first ones we made
actually let's call the allocation model
or the dispatch model so basically it's
very simple all the right handing
companies have some variant of this if
you're a customer and you want to go to
your destination which driver to be sent
to you and this is actually a very
feature driven model because there are
different ways that you can take
approach this problem so you can look at
the driver side you can say ok this
driver hasn't had an opportunity in a
long time this drivers heading to his
home area so you cannot optimize for
that we can give the customer what is
these the closest driver what is
eta to the destination all these types
of things or you can try and minimize
burn or increase revenue or and you know
all these other factors so this model
lives and dies by the features that you
have available to it so it's very
representative of our typical features
sorry our our use cases so we looked at
some of the features and so some of the
features you'd find our driver letter
features like the location speed the
direction ETA s you'd have customer
related features like the profile of the
customer behavior actions the region or
area related features like water how
many what is your supply base looking
live in that area or what is your demand
in an atrium or temporal features like
the time of the day that every week is
it holidays or an Indonesian you often
find that there are these big holidays
like Ramadan where the user behavior
changes completely and your models get
thrown off by that so you need to have
features that allow you to to account
for that so we took these features and
we kind of try to figure out what are
the common denominators of what our
system should be able to support so we
knew we needed to have entity level
grouping as well so that'll be the base
of what where our features are grouped
on its entities so support for entities
as well as composite entities are very
important and we knew that in training
and in serving the data would be in a
tabular form so it so instantly make
sense on the table level and then you'd
access specific feature columns by keys
on entity key of course you'd also have
composite entities and that'll be
something like well one area to another
area has a specific feature like the
average ETA between those two areas the
process of what creates those features
is another grouping so we can say that
some features of batch only so the
sequel transform to the sequel you'll
just have some more batch data but it
can also be an event stream then you
have granularities or important to
categorize your features in so that
you'll have different access patterns
based on the granularity because if you
have transactional data for example
that's your label data and you join
features onto that you're typically not
gonna join multiple granularity
data onto that you typically going to
have a single type of granularity
depending on the lid on the level of
granularity that you want your labels to
hear and then the interesting thing that
we found out is that some of the
features needed to be complex so we're
nice when we started the project we
anticipated that we'd only need integers
and floats and boolean z' and strings
and maybe some basic primitives for this
feature platform but what we later found
was that some of the models actually
required complex data structures
especially if you're working with
standard flow internal to the model the
model itself you can have
transformations so one of our data
scientists wrote a model that would take
GPS location data over 40 minutes of a
specific driver and if we try and
anticipate if the driver is spoofing is
the location and the drivers would
sometimes do this in order to get closer
to where the customers were so that it
would be assigned rights but this model
doesn't just take in primitives it takes
this whole beast this list of complex
values so that's something we needed to
support so the first thing we did was we
said okay if we're talking about
features as our main focus for this
platform we needed some way to
standardize what we meant by that so we
create came up with a specification
basically you can compare this to cuber
Nettie's manifests so basically this is
a minimal description of what a feature
is in this case we one of the things
that you'll notice here is this doesn't
tell you how to create the feature so
what we did at the start of this project
was we said we're gonna separate
creation of features from storage of
features and this was very important
because it means your store your feature
platform is agnostic to what creates a
feature because you sometimes will have
seas v's creating features you'll have
BQ or some data store or you'll have a
stream whatever the person grading
feature uses shouldn't determine how the
specification is made that can be a
separate system but the key things here
tonight are the value type being an
integer the entity that this feature is
told on
and then also some other useful things
like the owner description and where the
source code lives so so armed with this
feature specification our system had a
way to reason about features traveling
through from from from creation all the
way to access so once we had the
specifications we knew we needed to have
at least two ways of creating features
one batch way and one streaming workflow
so these two workflows or what we needed
to present to the data scientists as
tools in their toolbox and the way we
saw this was that the easy one would
always be the batch one because that's
where the exploration would happen and a
streaming one would cut we kind of the
last mile the last option where it's a
lot more complex and it requires more
engineering effort but it can always do
what you wanted to do as long as you
spend enough effort in that because
that'll always match your latency
requirements so the first one we try to
do is the sequel one or the batch one
and so we chose sequel because our
primary data store is bigquery it's a
relational database and the easiest it's
nothing the data science is the most
comfortable in so there's nothing really
spectacular about sequel so we just lost
them to write some sequel query it's
parameterised they con set parameters as
hard-coded and they have to use our
parameters and we actually try and
detect if they're trying to do really
complex joins or anything out of the out
of the ordinary so the first step is
writing a sequel query and then you'll
have multiple call columns coming from
that so you can have 10 features coming
from one query then you write a
specification so this is the interesting
part so I can reuse a lot of yem oh it's
a very convenient format for us to write
specifications and here we just have a
very basic creation specification so
this goes hand-in-hand with the sequel
query and it tells us how the columns
from a sequel query maps onto features
that I have definitions or
specifications within our system and
then it tells some basic things like
where were integers the slip-on
what scheduling frequency do you want to
have do you want you back Falls and
obviously the ownership as well but the
reason we took this approach was because
of problems we had with airflow
previously so we wanted to abstract away
the creation of DAGs in airflow I'm not
sure if you guys have used the airflow
before I'm sure some of you have but
what we found was that was a big source
of the technical data is that airflow is
very powerful and flexible but it allows
people to do things that are that make
it very difficult to one develop in the
first place because it gives you things
like templating but you can't really run
a template bash script or sequel script
easily unless you use air flow so you
tightly coupled to it
it also doesn't force you to
containerize so you're often you sort
that DAGs that would rewrite the path
variable or pull up a database or there
doesn't clean up or it's an offer itself
so we have our clusters becoming
corrupted by some of the diagrams so
what we did is we both the two cool
clockwork that would take in these
specifications if we take in the sequel
queries and it's basically a glorified
template er so as a data scientist you
write the specification and we put that
these specifications and sequel queries
as input into clockwork and it bolts all
your DAGs for air flow and this is an
idempotent process and you can just make
a change in your game or config and then
rebuild that dag and this was very
powerful for us and we went from a lot
of downtown and some of these pipelines
to virtually zero because you can just
as an engineer update the template and
then all of your decks benefit from that
so this is one of the things that we did
and so you'll have something like a dag
for driver daily or a customer daily or
a customer minute and it'll have all the
feature crap features that need to be
created there and all of the sequel
queries so this is how we solve the
batch process and we abstracted away the
engineering so let's talk about the
real-time aspect of this that's the
second thing that we need to solve we
looked at a lot of real-time streaming
or letting data processing libraries
because we're on Google Cloud
we did have an a bias towards some of
these tools but we basically considered
sparkling and beam and the one we
eventually chose was a patchy beam
mostly because of some of the the
concepts that it has so it was very
close between beam and flink because of
the concept of or the one advantage that
it has in unifying batching the stream
so this benefit is really powerful for
feature transformations because it means
you can define a feature once so if you
define feature once and blink or in beam
then you can reply to batch that
abounded data or you can fly to stream
data so that spoiler yeah that's all the
one problem that we have now we can
actually apply feature transformations
on BQ data on flat files like CVS on
events on caprica and we can produce an
output and it also solves our second
problem which is the consistency between
serving and training so if you have
multiple stores that have different
roles if if you have an upstream
transformation in beam you can just have
different i/o that sinks into the
different stores that you have so so
there's never an inconsistency and you
just set the exploration policy in your
serving store to be lower
maybe you just keep it on a okay this is
on a per feature basis but maybe days or
a month and you can have in your
training store build up that data over
months of time and the reason why beam
is very compelling for classes because
we can run on data flows over its
Committee server this we don't have to
manage any infrastructure and that's
really very useful for us yeah so we
don't have to have any fling or support
clusters although when we product
productize this platform we do allow you
to run it locally with art data file so
if you we have a Helmand stall that'll
use just flink runners to execute the
streaming pipelines and then finally
there's no lock-in because you can
migrate to any other runners so just an
example of feature transformation this
transformation looks at of trying to
find the driver truck count the
camper driver so based on events that
they have come in so this is just a very
basic example it essentially is it's
written in Python although typically
you'd write your transformations in Java
if you are writing beam code the Java
feature set is a lot larger than Python
Python is basically just lambdas there's
no windowing or any complex features
there I don't think you can even do
stream joins in Python yet so this one
just looks at some trips and fosters the
successful ones both the key out of that
or a map part of that and then does it
combine basically group by so it's a big
collection that you apply
transformations to and you're left with
another collection at the end and that's
that's all you need to do to do feature
transformations in beam so really
powerful but it does get complex if you
are writing java code if you're doing
stream joints if you're managing states
if you're doing any kind of complex
business logic like sessions you never
get around that problem of having to
deal with a lot of order events and
watermarks and those kinds of things but
beam really solves the use case of
real-time low latency features that we
sometimes require so now that we have
ways to publish our our features and
streamline for transformations we knew
that we needed to both the storage
itself so we looked at how are our users
would use it our clients would use it so
our user data scientists that want to
explore the storage that one is maybe
just do queries on the store both
datasets and then do some ETA on that
export or data analysis or trying to
model locally then in production we'd
have pipelines that could also hit the
store to Bob large data sets to Train
models and at the same time we'd have
models serving applications hitting the
store for low latest access of the same
features so we looked at a lot of
databases we looked at the hives and the
elastic search and the casandra's and
everything we basically evaluated
everything but that even remotely isn't
useful in any other company we realized
that we couldn't find one solution that
fit all of these use cases so we split
it up into
the stores into training stores and into
serving stores well there for the moment
we only have one training store so the
training store requirements are
large-scale data processing czar the
tens or hundreds of terabytes it should
easily be able to handle and it's
multi-tenant it should be multi tenant
and large pores key spaces so there's
applies to both serving and training so
one of the things that we found was that
let's say you have a feature that is an
area to area so it's a composite entity
between two areas and you bucket that
into 30-minute windows so it says it's
the average time it takes to drive
between or to take customer between two
areas in a specific time of the day that
would be a very large key space it
certainly about two billion keys in that
space but the data would be sparse so
you needed store that could allow you to
have sparse days data without it
becoming costly we need joins because we
have label data and you need joint
feature data to label data obviously the
store needs to be easy to use if you're
going to expose you to data Sciences
unless you're going to both a API or UI
on top of that so the one we eventually
settled on which is the same one we're
using for transformations and as our
store as well so this is our first store
is bigquery and the reason why bigquery
is so compelling for us is one is the
infrastructure it's completely managed
to sequel data science are familiar with
it there's already authentication and
access controls in our store it scales
to whatever we want it can handle any
amount of data that we can currently
throw at it it integrates with a lot of
the services that we use like ml engine
data flow GCS and it contains our
labeled data so we thought that if we
were to introduce a new store for
training let's say we chose five how
would we join the feature data on to our
train our label data so if our raw data
of transaction terrorism in bigquery
that is actually a big challenge so a
primary store at the moment and the one
that
selected above hive and presto and
object stores is this bigquery so in
terms of the serving store our
requirements were completely different
we needed very low latency reads and the
reason we need this is because if you
have a model serving application
typically or at least that Gajic we have
like 50 to 100 milliseconds to do
inference that's all we get you don't
get anything more than that so you don't
want to spend more than 10% or 20% of
your time doing boilerplate or non
business logic code so you don't want to
do feature collection or feature
transformations that really uses up a
lot of that SLO erase away most of the
time should be spent in your model so
that's where the processing should
happen so we wanted low latency reads
from the store then what often happens
is that if you've got Peaks so they says
a sports stadium empties out or a music
concert is on you often have large
spikes of users requesting bookings or
trips to go back home or to go to some
event and the drivers know this may
follow the news and so they're all gonna
be outside of the stadium or event hall
and you'll get feature lookups for all
of those same drivers over and over and
in your data store you have the same
keys being hit and for some data stores
this is actually a very bad thing and it
can really affect the performance when
you have those hotspots but we needed to
be able to handle either at peak load
150,000 key lookups for one feature per
second or we need some kind of clever
way to handle caching as well and of
course we need to store terabytes of
data because the key space problem is
the same for as force training so you'd
have you know terabytes and terabytes of
feature data that you on a store
theoretically this system needs support
at least a thousand to ten thousand ish
features that's the order of magnitude
that we were working in
we need persistence because one of the
interesting things about doing feature
transformations is that sometimes you
need to normalize features based on past
features so the store itself would need
to be hit during a stream transformation
so let's take something like driver's or
they say they say there's a restaurant
and there's giving out orders and you
don't know if they're giving out a lot
of orders or not so you want to
normalize they say the hourly order rate
based on the average already order rate
over the last three months so for that
you need persistence that data cannot be
just the ephemeral and then of course
then early scalable because we need to
be able to scale to any kind of load
especially if we're expanding into new
markets the amount of data is really
growing a lot so our primary store that
we chose was BigTable I'm not sure if
anybody here has used BigTable before
but the performance characteristics
really matched what we needed and it's
actually but we couldn't actually find
any data store or service that that
could match it on Google cloud so we're
in Google cloud so we're limited by the
fact that that is our our cloud provider
so we we couldn't choose from demo cloud
or open source technologies so the cool
thing about BigTable is that it actually
allows a lot of reason rise per second
so 10,000 per node combined reads and
writes and it guarantees that those will
be at ten milliseconds it's more lace
now this doesn't really sound that
amazing if you compare it to something
like Redis but there are some other
characteristics of BigTable that make it
really amazing actually
so one there's no infrastructure not
that's not entirely true so there are
nodes that provision but you don't
really manage those nodes you just write
and read to the database but the
interesting thing about BigTable is that
one it's a highly scalable so you can
just add nodes and it will linearly add
capacity so if you want in like if you
want a hundred thousand reads and writes
for a second then you just have ten
nodes so and that'll always be ten
milliseconds for read and write but the
best thing about it is the capacity that
it has so when we started we were using
register for a lot of our
serving and for our feature stores or
our basically our project level features
looms but we could never get across that
- they say 500 gigabytes range into the
terabyte range with Redis unless you'd
do something like shorting or plastering
the thing with BigTable is it actually
wants you to store a lot of data so if
you store anything less than 300
gigabytes and then it doesn't perform
well at all if you store terabytes of
data in it then it can really optimize
by the deadest laid out and so as our
primary store for a feature data that's
not read that quickly but relatively
quickly we use BigTable
but there's also a use case sorry and
it's persistent of course but there's
also a use case for rayless and redness
is our secondary store and the reason we
use Redis is for some feature values
like let's say the drivers location or
its speed or is or is altitude or things
like that where each update happens
basically on a per second or every
couple of second level so if you have
500,000 drivers and maybe a second
there's an update coming and you need to
have a stream confirmation and write
that into database it's gonna be very
expensive you do that in BigTable
because you can have to provision tens
of nodes so for that we use Redis and
then on a feature level in our
specification we say please use Redis
for this feature and the implication of
that is that that data is ephemeral if
that register note goes down you're
gonna lose it and we're gonna bring it
back up but there's no guarantee that
it's gonna be there in a month's time
and if you want that you need to use
BigTable but the cool thing about this
is that if there's any kind of failure
in the stream processing and stream
processing picks up again then if you
get this real surge of writes ranges can
easily handle that and it's not gonna
affect access because you've got two
sides here you've got the right into the
database and you've got the reads out
and if your rights are too high then
it's gonna affect your reads out of
course and the final thing we did and to
basically abstract this away from our
clients was to bolus serving API so the
serving API has a couple of features
basically what it is is an engine an API
that can query with a specific query
format and the API will deconstruct that
query and it was lookup all the feature
values from stores so it'll do register
cups and BigTable the cups and whatever
data store that we have in serving does
intelligent things like caching load
balancing across these nodes and does
failover it does rate limiting such as
quality of service control and
authentication this was a really
important for us because also this helps
a lot in terms just in terms of caching
if we're using BigTable and you're
hitting the same hotspots over and over
so this is how we solved basically going
from our three data stores bigquery
Cloud Storage kafka doing
transformations giving data science is a
way to author features for batch and
stream abstracting away all the
infrastructure of storage I don't have
to worry about that they only have to
worry about how can they query their
features in serving and how can they
train their model in on bigquery so the
bigquery is easy things export to CSV
and you can train your model on that but
but often you want to extend the
platform and we really like the approach
that kubernetes took in having these
manifests and specifications so we kind
of modeled our platform on that and that
you'd have essentially yamo files or
json files that you can extend and then
we can bold on top of this platform so
we can bolt a system that looks at the
feature stores feature specifications
and intact action on that essentially
that controller or C or D concept so a
very limited way in which we've done
this is through our own way of doing
annotations so we allow you to add
arbitrary configurations to the feature
specification and this allows us to do
more complex things inside of our
platform so one of the things we did is
so let's say you've got so in our system
in our use case everything is a Prada
buff and everything is basically stored
in or triple transmitted in bytes on the
wire
so even if your type is an integer or a
string it's still gonna be sent as proto
so if you can imagine now if you store
that value in bigquery and you give some
access to that table
it's not gonna be text it's not going to
be a value it's gonna be bytes it's
unreadable so one of the ways we solve
that is by just giving you a way to
define what your data is so we just
specify some key values and you say this
is my data type it's a photograph when
you're going when you write to the
warehouse just decode that Marshall and
into JSON and then our system or the
platform itself wall has specific hook
points where it will trigger these
conditional steps and it'll decode the
data and then it'll store it in the
right format for you another thing that
we did here was to add the option to do
just distribution checking so this is
basically a way that we do in flight
data checking when you're streaming in
your raw data and transforming features
and then storing it at the store step we
do a check to see that there's nothing a
normal is about your data and where did
you do that is by having options as well
where you can say the discrete value
limit should be within these range rate
ranges within this range and then what
should happen when there's anomalous
event should you warn or if you prevent
the right to go through and this check
actually happens both at ingestion into
the store as well as access from serving
API and obviously you can change the
specification off your data is rewritten
into the stores and that's why we have
dual checks both on right and on read
but this is this option section is
really the one of the areas that we're
gonna focus on adding functionality
especially when you want to couple the
creations pipelines into the storage
pipeline sorry the storage layer and
then the next thing we both was a
feature Explorer so internally this
platform is called feast it's just a
combination of features store and we
wanted to solve the discovery problem
and we did that by building a simple UI
where you could explore
all the features that have been defined
within within our platform and we can
look at features and entities you can
look at the jobs that are currently
running so if there's an ingestion
running if there's any activity on some
of the topics in Kafka how many features
are being read in there and then you can
draw into the specific features and have
a look at more detail on them so this is
one of the components that we're
currently building out and like the goal
of this this UI will be well these are
some of the things that we want
we won't discover it so if somebody
offers a feature they should just it
should be visible here and it should be
accessible we want a really a case where
people are developing features and silos
we want to have a situation where a new
joiner can come on to join the team
train a model without doing any feature
engineering whatsoever and that you just
come out to this platform select as it
like a shopping cart the features that
they want exported to a CSV or to some
table and then train the model and
feature management is also something
that we wanted so stopping and starting
features stopping ingestion doing adding
validation changing the data type or
version of the feature so and then one
of the things that that we're doing now
is that when you've got a completes to a
feature platform and you're logging
ingestion you're logging creation you're
looking at how these features are used
for training models you're looking at
what feature is the most indicative or
most useful for the model to predict
outcomes which features are being used
the most for your serving API and what
are the confidences in the predictions
that that model has in production if you
log all of those things together you
actually have a very powerful picture I
could get a picture of which features
are useful and based on that so our
approach at the moment is we expose that
data to data scientists and I mean and
then when new data sounds come on they
can have a look at those really really
powerful features and also as an
engineer that also gives me an idea of
which features I should be targeting for
QA because often somebody's writing this
feature nobody looks
the code accredited but you as an
engineer need to obviously validate that
and on this platform you can also then
look at the system health there's all
your stores are holding up you can look
at your link to the source code if you
want to basically get the source code
you can do that you can look at the
bigquery view so so this really becomes
a center point where people can discuss
a feature and the standard of the
feature so at the end of the day just to
kind of summarize we built a platform
that one solve the the way that we
abstract engineering from data
scientists it gives them a way to author
author features train their models on
these features serve on these features
and production and discover new features
they don't have to worry about any kind
of infrastructure management or writing
et Al's or anything and air flow anymore
like it's simply full focus on the
business logic and in terms of the time
effect that this has had so definitely
this is dramatically changed the way
that we do data science it dramatically
decrease the amount of engineering
effort that data scientists do it's a
much more engineering effort for the
engineers of this project but because we
have a ratio of about four data sciences
to one engineer inside the data science
team this is very useful because it
frees up a lot of our data store
engineers to focus on the product itself
instead of focusing on the projects and
then just the impact for the time to
market because we don't have to reball
features or rebuild streams improve
customer experience because our models
are more accurate we have more features
to choose from we can support more
customers per data scientists because
they are there are they're more leverage
at the moment and ultimately the
smelliest infrastructure right that's
for me thanks
[Music]
[Applause]
hi thanks it's great um one question
about you sort of talk about removing
the need for the data scientists to
author the features themselves kind of
thing but then you kind of I'm I've just
missed a bit in terms of the beam
processing are they authoring that
section themselves well that well
they're differently involved because
they didn't generally define the
business logic that goes into that
because especially with some features is
very complex and but we can't so it
depends on the type of feature that you
make if you're just doing something
that's basically like an input lambda
output that's very easy
data science can write that if it's
anything that's complex with joins with
windowing with watermarks and early
firing and late firing there's no way
that the data science will do that so
that's a joint process at the moment
yeah but we needed something that could
support that yeah cool yeah yeah it's
not easy want to solve
you